happy friday we are bumping around these
winds have been
muscling us around for the last 24 hours
this has
been a very blustery start to your
friday and a chilly start this is cold
for may
to get down into the low 50s like we are
this morning and then you got to factor
in there is a wind chill
west southwest winds have still been up
over 30 miles an
hour sustained winds 15 to 20 plus out
there so
it's cool you'll be sorry if you don't
grab some long sleeves a sweater a
jacket look at the 50s
valley wide 40s out at red rock and
below freezing
up at kyle canyon where they could see
some snow in the higher elevations of
the spring mountains today
they're already seeing the snow in utah
higher elevations of arizona just a
little bit
and northern nevada's been getting some
snow so if you're headed up to the
mountains today
boy take a warmer jacket wind advisories
now have been extended reissued for the
lake the river
and southern clark county over to
northwest arizona southeast california
where winds today expected to again be
45 to 50 miles an hour
red rock had six near 65 mile an hour
winds yesterday it will not be that
rough today
but we're still going to get maybe 30 to
35 mile an hour wind so it's still going
to be a little challenging outdoors
fire weather warning still issued for
the same areas where we have wind
advisories today
not for las vegas but we still have to
be on alert for that still dry still
windy
45 on the mountain and by the afternoon
some of that moisture could circulate
into our area
give us snow above 6000 feet in our
local mountains and maybe
a shower or two around the valley we're
not going to rule that out
so 72 for the high in this this late in
may
wow mid 70s much less wind as we get
into a saturday
and then a very comfortable 82 for
sunday 90s return next week